- CALL DAK.
CALL DAKOTA PRESCOTT.
How do I work this thing?
- Shhhh, guys, keep it down.
Hello, Mr. Jones.
- Hey, bud, just calling for our
daily contract negotiation!
How about four years, $20 million a year,
and I’ll throw in a half a dozen oil rigs?
- I want $35 million a year.
- [Laughs] Oh, Dakky, you're ridiculous.
That’s what Russell Wilson makes, hahaha.
Oh. You’re serious.
- I deserve it, sir.
I’m a great leader.
Just have the caterers come in. It’s fine.
- OK, how about $25 million,
and I'll let you add a fifth play into
Mike McCarthy’s playbook?
Are you having another hootenanny?!
- Uh, no. I made this ice sculpture myself.
- Good. We need to be socially distant.
OK, here, let me add Zeke.
- Sup, Jerry?
- Hey, Zeke, tell Dak we want him on the team.
- HEY, DAK, WE WANT YOU ON THE TEAM.
- You paid Zeke.
You paid Amari.
I need to get what’s mine.
- Wait, did you invite Jason Garrett
to your little hoedown, Dak?
Ah commo—shouldn’t he be in New York?
- Oh right, I gotta go.
- No, sir, you’re old, and you're
just imagining things again.
- I do sometimes think it’s the '90s,
but it makes me so happy…
- It’s a different time now.
JARED GOFF got $33.5 million.
I’m better than him, right?
- Right.
OK, maybe I can convince Amari
to give me back some of that $100 million.
- Hello, Mr. Jones—
- AHHHHHHHHHHHHhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh!
- How about $36 mill,
and I invite you to my next illegal party?
- If you.
- Liked
- This video
- Subscribe below
- For more.
- Or we’re not
- Jason
- And Jason McCourtey.
- No, you’re Devin.
- I’m pretty sure you’re Devin.
- Which of us is Devin?
- Uh, you!
- ME?
- I’ll be Devin.
- Thanks Jason.